dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here I am
really excited to show this to you as I
was looking to make this episode for
quite a while you'll see lots of
beautiful slow-motion footage during the
narration and at first it may seem
disconnected from the narrative but by
the end of the video you'll understand
why they look the way they do now before
we proceed let's talk about the
difference between interpolation and
extrapolation interpolation means that
we have measurement points for a given
quantity and would like to know what
happened between these points for
instance we have two samples of a
person's location at four and at five
o'clock and we'd like to know where the
guy was at 4:30 however if we are doing
extrapolation we are interested in
guessing a quantity beyond the reach of
our sample points for instance
extrapolation would be predicting what
happens after the very last frame of the
video in our earlier episode we talked
about financial extrapolation make sure
to have a look it was super fun the link
is in the video description optical flow
is really useful because it can do this
kind of interpolation and extrapolation
for images so let's do one of them right
now
you see which it will be in a second so
this is a classical scenario that we
often encounter when producing a new two
minute tapers episode here we have a 25
or 30 frames per second video on a 60
frames per second timeline this means
that roughly every other frame is
duplicated and offers no new information
you can see this as I step through these
individual frames and the more astute
fellow scholars immediately would point
out that wait we have a lot of before
and after image pairs so we could do a
lot better why don't we try to estimate
what happened between these images and
that is exactly what we call frame
interpolation interpolation because it
is something between two known
measurement points and if you run the
optical flow algorithm that can
accomplish this we can fill in these
doubled frames with new ones that
actually carry new information
so the ratio here was roughly two-to-one
roughly every other frame provides new
information super cool
so what are the limits of this technique
what if we artificially slow the video
down so that it's much longer so not
only every other but most of the frames
are just duplicates this results in a
boring and choppy animation can we fill
those in to note that the basic optical
flow equations are written for tiny
little changes in position so we
shouldn't expect it to be able to
extrapolate or interpolate any quantity
over a longer period of time but of
course it always depends on the type of
motion we have at hand so let's give it
a try
you
as you can see with optical flow the
algorithm has an understanding of the
motions that take place in the footage
and because of that we can get some
smooth buttery slow-motion footage that
is absolutely mesmerizing almost like
shooting with a slow-motion camera and
note that the majority of these frames
were not containing any information and
this motion was synthesized from these
distant sample points that are miles and
miles away from each other really cool
however it is also important to point
out that optical flow is not a silver
bullet and it should be used with
moderation and special care as it can
also introduce nasty artifacts like the
one that you see here this is due to an
abrupt high frequency change that is
more difficult to predict than a slow
and steady translation or rotation
motion to avoid these cases we can use a
much simpler frame interpolation
technique that we call frame blending
this is a more naive technique that
doesn't do any meaningful guesswork and
computes the average of the two results
why don't we give this one a try two or
even better let's have a look at the
difference between the original Charpy
footage and the interpolated versions
with frame blending and optical flow if
we do that we see that frame blending is
unlikely to give us nasty artifacts but
in return the results are significantly
more limited compared to optical flow
because it doesn't have an understanding
of the motion taking place in the
footage so the question is when to use
which well until we get an algorithm
that is able to adaptively decide when
to use what it still comes down to
individual judgment and sometimes quite
a bit of trial and error I'd like to
make it extremely sure that you don't
leave this video thinking that this is
the only application of optical flows
it's just one of the coolest ones but
this motion estimation technique also
has many other uses for instance if we
have an unmanned aerial vehicle it is
really great if we can endow it with an
optical flow sensor because then it will
be able to know in which direction it
needs to rotate to avoid a tree or
whether it is stable or not at a given
point in time and with your support on
patreon we were not only able to bump up
the resolution of future 2-minute
Persepolis to 4k but we're also running
them at true 60 frames per second which
means that every footage can undergo
either a frame blending or optical flow
step to make the animation smoother and
more enjoyable for you this takes a bit
of human labor and is computationally
expensive but our new two minute papers
Rick is now capable of handling this it
is fantastic to see that you fellow
scholars are willing to support the
series and through this we can introduce
highly desirable improvements to the
production pipeline this is why we thank
you at the end of every episode for your
generous support you fellow scholars are
the best YouTube audience anywhere and
who knows maybe one day we'll be at a
point where two minute papers can be a
full-time endeavor and we'll be able to
make even more elaborate episodes as I
am tremendously enjoying making these
videos that would be absolutely amazing
have you found any of these disturbing
optical flow artifacts during this
episode have you spotted some of these
in other videos on YouTube let us know
in the comment section so we can learn
from each other thanks for watching and
for your generous support now see you
next time
[Music]
you